it's so great to see you sir in person
his uh is a news comedy special comedy
monster is available now on netflix the
fun tour dates you can see him all
throughout february and march and more
you can go to jimgafigan.com for that
the great jim gaffigan good to see you
man thanks for having me it's very
exciting to be here it's uh
it's fun to hear some of this talk which
talk are you referring to just the whole
uh the the you know the mvp the nfl
stuff yes sir i mean i'm i'm from
indiana so it's like i'm a colts fan so
it's just
it's been a brutal couple weeks
they you know they went from the team
nobody wanted to face the playoffs to a
team nobody is seeing in the playoffs in
two weeks in just a two-game span it's
just like that
a collapse and it's almost like no one
like the collapse is so
pronounced no one's even pointing
fingers they're like i don't even know
who to blame
like we're still in shock it's like it's
nobody's fault
it's like we had a good week in practice
it's just like and there's a civility i
was thinking the colts organization like
you know um of course irsay was like it
was my fault and you're like i don't
know if it was your fault
i don't know
i don't think the owner
should be blamed for like uh
massive talent kind of not coming
together right but it's like peaking
right because aaron rodgers had the
worst game of his career the first game
yep and then now he's
perfect he's it's really unbelievable
how and and then just of course all of
us in my world of industry where you
know you have to have a take week to
week after that first week it's like i
don't know if rogers has his teammates
all together he's off season does he
really even care does he even want to be
there and now we have our answer you
know it's like it's just calmness that
people like him and brady have and
obviously they're passionate yes but the
calmness
is
it's not it's inhuman
it's inhuman like well you know i mean
because we've seen rogers yeah you know
hey settle down
settle down
and we're all like
and he's like yeah you know
after the off season he's like it's
gonna be fine it's like he's
in the way he's the best dad ever he's
the calm dad
he's not he's the calm dad he's not
going to overreact or anything he's like
oh we'll figure this out the car ran out
of gas but we'll get gas
it's just like unbelievable
especially i thought when you said com i
just thought he and brady in the face of
people trying to tear his head off too
you know what i mean and then just be
able to play the way that they are i
mean just brady navigating the
antonio brown thing is pretty amazing
have you ever seen anything
has anybody ever done that in your
profession just stripped down and then
just quit does that ever happen no on
the stage where it's where look i mean
takes his shirt
that as off
to antonio brown as anything
i think most comedians are a little bit
like antonio brown like if he decided he
wanted to be a comedian no one would be
surprised you know i mean like there's a
lot of people that are like
yeah okay so comedians are an eccentric
strange bunch we go on stage and seek
approval from strangers you can't say
that's normal
so it's like it's just a way of putting
it and also trying to figure out what
they want to hear in real time as well
but drama it's like
the drama that's occurred this season
yes it is it is our real housewives
right that's what it is it is a reality
show yes sir i agree with you it's a
narrative generating machine the nfl
week to week where you just never know
and that's why the playoffs are so great
because it's been a year of week-to-week
narratives built up to win or lose games
and it's going to affect everything the
whole thing like rogers is so happy in
green bay right now and you you hear in
his voice what how well he's getting
along with the guy who he apparently
spent months this fight
right exactly right and then if he gets
one and done in the playoffs then what
you know what i mean it could yeah like
that week off
it's so weird you think of like the week
off could be
that could be bad right i mean it's
momentum but like i do like a podcast
and i'm exhausted i talked to a friend
for an hour i got to take a nap it's
like these guys take
these they're the best athletes in the
world they take a week off and they're
like i forgot how to do this like i it's
weird but then again it also helps and
they're getting uh
that defense that offensive tackle back
which is huge that's right and then a
couple of their defenders they're
they're one of those rare one seeds
that's getting healthy as things move on
i've got jim gaffigan here on the rich
eisen show the new comedy special comedy
monster available right now
on netflix how have you been
you know doing comedy in the middle of
all this stuff it's pretty weird you
know it's uh you travel around um and
you know in you know
la new york it's a different vibe you go
into red states and it's like
you know i'm the only one with a mask on
i look like a hypochondriac i'm wearing
a mask and everyone's like what is he
doing
but uh it's strange you know it's like
there's different statuses at different
venues you don't want to perform for
people that have their mouth covered
typically
but i'm grateful to be out there it's
weird the whole it's very confusing i
mean my parents haven't been vaccinated
which is weird i mean mm-hmm i mean
they've been dead a couple decades
you know
they have grandchildren you know what i
mean
i don't know if anyone's uncommon that
was a wind-up i didn't see the pitch
like i didn't see that pitch coming it's
weird like anyone who's lost a parent
there there is this period where you're
like i can't even talk about it don't
even bring it up someone brings
someone's like hey
uh your mom was a great lady you're like
thanks i'm gonna go in the other room
and cry and then you get to a point
where you still feel the pain but you
eventually are like all right
we're gonna move on my parents died and
rich eyes and killed him
yeah
i didn't see that one coming either i
didn't think i'd be the punchline on
that one but well thank you
now did you watch comedy monster on
netflix you should have watched yeah of
course there's so much stuff to watch so
i appreciate if people are like
there's like a new show every week i i i
cannot watch um anything that's kind of
overly serious or apocalyptic or
dystopian i want to laugh man yeah like
i literally want to sit down forget
about everything and just laugh and
that's what you're doing you know what i
mean like that i'm into that big time so
and again that's available now uh on
netflix um i i gotta bring this up um
uh put up the photograph if you don't
mind um on jeff garland uh put this one
out uh the other day yeah that's you
right in the middle behind rickles um
and i was like describe garland he's got
jack black in a headlock yeah um that's
queen latifah john stamos john mayer and
then to your right is the great bob
saget what was this night ma'am what's
going on
i mean this bob saget
had i mean it's like how is somebody i
mean obviously
we've all heard and we you know people
know you you interact with bob sagan
you're like is this guy
for real or is he kind of conning me or
is he he he was that level of
you know he could pull in queen latifah
and john mayer for a benefit because
this was a
research foundation and he would do it
once in new york and once in la and he
would
there was just a
it was in the entertainment industry i
feel like you run into these people
where you're like oh this is how
we should aspire to treat each other
like there he was not somebody who was
caught up in hierarchy he was you know
full house was a silly show he was not
caught in the web of that like of a
being a former star of a sitcom
he was you know his soul was that of a
comedian
and so uh you know that comedian family
is very
about authenticity and he kept
searching and trying to find more
authenticity but the kindness his
kindness
would melt anyone do you know what i
mean like you'd be like well i don't
know i don't know what i'm going to do
here and people would you know queen
latifah showing up for
a benefit it's like these benefits
in l.a and new york are constant and he
has like don rickles
showing up to it and that's the type of
person
he was you're like all right i want to
do something nice for him so he'd call
you up and say hey can you do a set
tonight fly to l.a and i'm like all
right
but he would also have done like
15 things for you where you know if
something bad happened he'd be
the person to text you it's like i think
he spent like two hours a day
sending nice messages to people
it was pretty amazing
and that looks like a blast of a knife
oh my gosh that's so fun i mean just
like the you know wrinkles what was this
what was it
he was just sitting in a he was pretty
up there so he was sitting in a chair
they brought a microphone to him
and he just tore into everyone he just
tore into everyone and it was
it's it's a unique skill to like be able
to like
take a knife out and cut everyone's
you know achilles tendon out and just
they love you and so that was pretty
amazing and then
i mean it's weird like john you know you
know that he's buddies with john stamos
but like jimmy kimmel showing up jimmy
kimmel i remember i sat next to jimmy
kimmel and there was an auction and
jimmy kimmel bought like some trip to
vegas which we know is where jimmy
kimmel is from yeah yeah and i'm like
what are you doing he goes i just you
know i got to do it for bob you know so
he bought this trip for like fifty
thousand dollars he's not going to use
it
it's amazing
but it was a good you know like when you
were in high school and you you had
these senior
uh these upperclassmen where you're like
you know what i want to behave like that
that's what sag it was like you're like
you know what i want to be like that
type of guy who does favors helps people
out is always kind of like a positive
influence sweetheart of a guy man yeah
yeah i would i would uh give away like
nfl network tours to to that event too
you know and he he and he would be the
one calling up to say what's your email
i'll hold you up like and he's the one
doing it like bob like what you know
yeah
yeah how do you handle all of this yeah
and again it's like a level of
commitment and he loved stand up and
that's
you know the weird thing i think people
think that comedians
are competitive and don't get along when
the reality is is that we're so
eccentric and that same kind of um
there's a fraternal nature to it so yeah
there is uh doesn't matter what type of
comedy you do there's a mutual respect
and that's uh jim gaffigan here on the
rich eisen show the fun tour dates
coming up
um you're going to you're you're going
all over the place man lafayette
louisiana on the 4th beaver creek
colorado on the 16th are you going to be
here in town for the super bowl are you
going to because that's coming i don't
know you know i miss those you know the
l.a i well i you know sometimes when the
colts would be i would
uh entertain the uh
the owners right didn't you do one of
those i did one i
performed for the owners and
um
i remember i didn't realize jerry jones
was that tall and also
um
uh i don't know her name miss mara just
like her hair yes just bombing in front
of billionaires is just you didn't bomb
all right i mean it was it was you know
it's a it's an interesting group well
hold on a second did you roast them
don't forget no that's kind of that's
not your will i know that i should have
but like it's also
you know there's different you know like
there's wealthy people
and then there's nfl owner wealthy like
dear i mean like these people
they're not oh i gotta go to the grocery
store they're not going to the grocery
store
i mean they're like i don't even know
what he would be like they don't
go on vacation they buy countries they
don't you know i mean it's
it's a different thing so you're you're
that being said
is like the nicest most down to earth
yeah and he's got all of these um
artifacts from the history of music
that's ridiculous
i think he owns a version of the magna
carta what yeah he's like
he also pulls in like
amazing people you're like wait a minute
am i standing next to rob lowe and
steven stills or what you know it's just
like he knows musical legends
yeah i mean ryan leaf once brought in uh
a letter that he had gotten from a fan
that just said hey i've got this letter
that i want to send you
and it was a letter that hunter s
thompson had written jim irsay
telling him to draft leaf over the
manning kid
and it was like an artifact
that we then called up jim irsay and
said can you verify this because that
absolutely happened like honorable
you know what i mean like so he is
i don't know how many other owners in
the nfl have a hunter s thompson letter
telling him the draft ryan
it seems like there it is right there
there is that's it right there dear
james in response to your addled request
for a quick 30 million dollar loan to
secure the services of the manning kid i
have to say no at this time but the leaf
boy is another matter he looks strong
and manning doesn't or at least not
strong enough to handle that welcome to
the nfl business for two years without a
world-class offensive line how are you
fixed it left tackle for the next few
years james think about it you don't
want to china dial back there when that
freak sap comes crashing in
okay let me know if you need money for
leaf i expect to be very rich when this
depp movie comes out
there it
i don't know the marvel universe but
like that feels like
different universes like well that
spider-man's not supposed to be in this
universe
like i mean it's like i don't think
it's like it might as well have been
like mark twain kind of chiming in yeah
we're going into the earth universe
right how to deal with uh a life after
post andrew luck you know i mean it's a
weird take on he's an interesting cat
jimmer say okay so everybody can go to
jimgafigan.com for tickets and more tour
dates um february uh you're going to be
in chicago i'm going to be in chicago
i'm excited i grew up in that
area i grew up in indiana which is uh
most people in chicago don't realize is
right next door
whenever i'm there they're like uh i'll
be like yeah i'm from northwest indiana
they're like where's that i'm like 20
minutes away
20 minutes away
gary indiana's right on the corner right
right there region rats
you know it's rust belt which if people
don't know that's kind of like kind of
like the bible belt but instead of
religion there was crushing unemployment
and it really turns out some optimism
comedy monster available now on netflix
at jim gaffigan on twitter and instagram
i follow him you should too jim this has
been a pleasure man it's great to see
you in person thank you for coming in
here man be be well and safe on the road
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here